[Music]  no I think for me I've always thought  that like a katana sword it's very  useful because you can get some distance  and it's really sharp super easy to just  smash and kill I couldn't imagine them  the components or could be with you  looks like the biggest gun we're like  low the bullet but now I think you're ok  right on a tank  I think I would take the sword of my  character because guns never run out of  bullets haha Layton the taurus you can  pull it off a little longer I wouldn't  take doc I have like everything we laugh  sell ours all eyes like she's in an epic  fight scene and you've got a little nail  gun really super hip so funny I would  have probably picked you know when my  machine gun  you